24h sur
24 à la nouvelle orléon depuis 7
génération que la famille et h on les
appelle n
[Musique]
nation
did you see my
babying down railad
TR tell me oh the
[Musique]
girl
h try to get back
home
W up some
other the girl
[Musique]
all can you
see
me
good she forgten all about me oh girl
[Musique]
can you tell
me girl
[Musique]
man have you seen
that you tell
[Musique]
me
you tell
[Musique]
me
plutôt black memory que Public Enemy pas
du tout Black Panther c'était Neville
Brother idiot international modi
national panfletire antibicentenaire
mais qui le fera terre avec la
Marseillaise plutôt balaise voici Marc
édard NAB crucifiez-moi vous me